love heart that's Megan Fox yep Mila
Kunis was confused for Megan Fox I think
it's funny and she had the ultimate
response to the mix-up
by the way and the fact that you thought
it was her I'm gonna pass on that one my
friend
it all went down back in September when
Mila was leaving Jimmy Kimmel Live in
New York City oh
and now the clip has resurfaced even
going viral on Tick Tock
I love her that's Megan Fox fantastic
by the way Mila was also part of another
moment making its rounds on the internet
when she was booed by the Jimmy Kimmel
Live audience
[Music]
yeah seems the New York crowd had some
opinions on the actress like when she
said she's not a native from the Big
Apple you seemed like you could be a New
Yorker but you're not a New Yorker right
no I'm not you're not I was what
someone booed you well what's wrong with
your audience
I'm sorry and when she admitted she
skipped out on trying Pizza during her
first visit did you have pizza for the
first time of year in New York
are you ready
no
I know I'm going this audience is
something but when Mila explained that
pizza was a big part of her life growing
up because her dad was a delivery man
she was met with more booze there's
this story just to get another book
oh
that's Pizza oh
yeah Mila was a good sport over the
collective heckling but throughout
another shocking fact bracing for one
more final blow I mean I hate Pizza you
hate Pizza
[Applause]
[Music]
well one thing Mila's not getting booed
for her return is the iconic Jackie Bird
card in the That 70s Show reboot that
90s show
s
me with joy yep Mila along with the rest
of the OG gang will make brief cameos as
the story continues 20 years later
welcome back to chances it's always an
honor to have your hair in my chair I
think the fact that the creators and the
writers are all together again you'll
know the secret sauce is going to be
there and while the series will follow a
new cast of youngsters Mila says fans
won't be disappointed it's very good
it's great in fact and I think that
anyone that's ever watched 70s that was
a fan loved it I think would be very
very very very happy with how they the
inciting incident of this of the whole
series
[Music]